das ist was wir unter welcher etwas
gesagt bekommt weil mein video habe
hatte ich hoffe natürlich geht gut ich
habe heute den cedric dabei monsanto
talk als wäre dieser kanal fünf bis zehn
leute hast du ja aber so heißt ein
youtube kanal ja das stimmt ja das video
entsteht eigentlich sehr spontan es
wahrhaben wollen sie gerade gesagt ich
glaube wir machen mal eine getränken
erwartet wir waren sehr viel auf youtube
unterwegs haben das ganze bei einfach
peter schaar ich oder der hat musste
seinen namen ändern weil fahrrad stress
gemacht ich habe hier ein spinner ohne
gewichte den ersten wirklich den hut
irgendwie weiterhelfen
ich würde sagen sie nachher gar nicht
lange prinzip ist ganz einfach wir beide
eine augenbinde turi hat eben getränke
angekauft die dürfen nicht gesehen haben
es sind sowohl bekannte getränke als
auch also eigentlich sind es nur
bekannte getränk aber ist in sachen die
sind schweres gesagt diese nicht so
schwer müssen sind erwarten eins gegen
eins und ich mit sagen wir schauen ob
wir mehr würde der welt der schneller
errät gewinnt den punkt so zu sagen wir
dann aus ihr macht ihr so das hier ist
das erste es ist kein die kritiker sind
okay 3
weil heute war die stopp stopp stopp
stopp stopp stopp 321 action racer
existent aber was für eine
ich kenne ich viele unnütze pump würden
wie das heißt bei monster bekannt ich
weiß genau welches das aber mit fällt
der name ich ein monster rockstar
richtig ja wie die alte
ich hatte diesen anderen im ich habe
diesen anderen kommen
diese hätten alle so weißt du irgendwas
mit irgendwas mit ehrmann vom effekt
effekt genau dass dadurch wird das man
hat einfach schon wurde es eigentlich
gemerkt also gerochen das geld weg ist
wenn man das stimmt jemand nach vorne wo
viele leute 1 0 für teams scheinen jetzt
ein bisschen schwieriger fried
verantworten war schmidt irgendwie
scheiße oder voll süß machen wir mehr
ein es sei auf jeden fall oder das heißt
sie hier
herisau na ja meine mit mut eine blaue
glaube dass richtig glauben
sehr schön sind die aus einer denn an
keinem ausgefallen ist
das ist das nächste getränk mal gespannt
ob wir das erwartet erst die marke ok
also sozusagen zum beispiel bilder ok 21
was ist das ich habe keine ahnung
doch ich hab ich auch aber ich weiß
jetzt schon dass da nicht drauf kommen
werden von der betonung hat sich das
wasser
wenn man die augen zu dann hat man alles
viel intensiver lässt gar nicht wie ich
das nicht weil sie zugleich nicht drauf
kommen werde
normalerweise
ich werde jetzt nicht wird er gleich
nicht draufkommt witzigsten ja jetzt
wohl ironisch sein können voll witzig
war die staffel sind dass diese tetra
pak weil ich bock egal dann sagt die
marke ist kaffeesatz welcher geschmack
nur ich kann nicht diese ich weiß genau
welcher dieser bunte nein hier richtig
stimmt ja ja aber ich habe nicht in der
rheder um das capri sonne sie so süß ist
wie könnte ich diese scheiße zu
ertrinken als etwas verkehrt leben
eigentlich so komisch komisch wo ich ja
mal also wie stehts jetzt für dich hast
du ja ja zuerst für mich das schon
diagnose leute ich habe gehört das ist
der punkt geht an mich so beide was du
denkst du bekommen dass schneider hat
und nicht ganz so kann etwa ein stalker
cola cola falsch dr
falls afri cola richtig ja
deutschland muss nach dieser stelle auch
mal sagen ihr denkt wahrscheinlich dass
es leicht aber das ist echt richtig
schwer also ich hätte das auch
vielleicht eingeschätzt als ich dir die
hölle sagt lasst die channels machen so
du hast dich erst mal so ganz jungen
direkte erwarten
es fehlen 22 ja okay leute willkommen zu
absoluten alle entscheidenden runde habe
auch zu müssen
es steht 2 2 die macher einig das hast
du bist das finale
das hört sich schon echt scheiße sagen
oder so oder so dünnschiss hört sich das
nicht richtig ja nicht ein
zeit bleibt gott war die trostlose welt
warten sagt richtig junge das ist ja
aber was du limetten gesagt das ist dass
jugendliche
du hast wahrscheinlich richtigen schluck
genommen hast gesagt hat ja macht
langsam ich gebe euch das gleichzeitig
schauen was falsch ist denke ich habe
einfach jeden die gelassen haben und das
ist doch dieses kleine warum willst du
dich so gut aus mit getränken er ich
kenne solche phase hatte einen
getränkeladen
heute nachdem eine haben absolut scheiße
aus dem was mit der getränke talent ich
hoffe natürlich ist er durchgefallen der
kamera die ganze zeit nach oben anstatt
unten
leute lasst noch nach oben dafür diese
geniale idee und checkt auf jeden fall
das video war auf dem kanal hat ist ganz
oben in der video stellung von den
klassen aber da gibt es dann nach oben
und schreibt den kommentare alex ist
viel cooler als du
wir sehen uns morgen wahrscheinlich
wieder frei haut ein
bist du bist ja ein paar minuten das
darf so nicht bis zum nächsten können
[Musik]